bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette petite vidéo où aujourd'hui
on va relever le défi de raconter toute
l'histoire de l'évolution humaine avec
juste un crâne parce que figurez-vous
que sur le crâne dès l'homo sapiens de
l'homme humain de l'être humain moderne
il y a toutes les cicatrices de son
évolution depuis plus de 500 millions
d'années tout est là il suffit
simplement de savoir où chercher donc
aujourd'hui on va se faire une petite
virée
ostéologique et aussi un grand voyage
dans le temps puisque nous allons
remonter le fil de l'évolution d'Homo
sapiens depuis les tous premiers
poissons il y a plus de 500 millions
d'années jusqu'à Homo sapiens modernes
alors on commence par les vertébrés donc
les vertébrés ce qu'on appellerait
l'ancêtre de tous les poinçons de tous
les poissons et de tous les animaux qui
ont une colonne vertébrale comment
est-ce qu'on voit sur Homo sapiens ce
que Homo sapiens est invertébré va tout
simplement parce qu'il a un crâne le
simple fait d'avoir un crâne fait de
vous invertébré aucun invertébré n'a de
crâne le crâne il protège le cerveau
chez Homo sapiens il est fait en os dur
mais chez un requin par exemple il est
fait de petites capsules cartilagineuses
mais en tout cas quoi qu'il arrive tous
les vertébrés ont un crâne et c'est une
caractéristique que l'on partage avec
l'ancêtre en commun de tous les
vertébrés qui a vécu entre 500 et 550
millions d'années à la louche donc on
est au Cambria
on monte un petit peu dans l'évolution
on va se rapprocher petit à petit on va
voyager dans le temps de plus en plus
vers l'époque moderne et on va se
rapprocher de plus en plus d'Homo
sapiens donc on bouge un peu dans le
temps on se rapproche de nous nous
sommes il y a environ 450 à 500 millions
d'années et voici l'ancêtre que nous
partageons avec les natostomes alors
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un knatostome
c'est un poisson à mâchoire comme les
requins par exemple donc les gnatostomes
sont des poissons à mâchoire et de ce
fait ils ont tous des dents et oui parce
que si vous n'avez pas de mâchoire comme
une lampe proie par exemple à quoi bon
avoir des dents donc les fêtes d'avoir
des dents montrent que vous êtes un
gâteau Storm et évidemment le fait
d'avoir une mandibule alors là maman dit
bulle s'articule pas avec mon crâne car
je ne me balade pas avec des têtes de
mort donc tout ça ce sont des copies
évidemment ce ne sont pas des vrais gens
morts que je tiens dans les mains donc
ça c'est pour les gnatostumes nous
sommes des gnatostumes mais nous ne
sommes pas n'importe quel une atostumes
nous sommes des natostumes
ostéiciens alors ça veut dire quoi tous
ces gros mots ça veut dire que nous
sommes des poissons
osseux en tout cas nous partageons un
ancêtre en commun avec tous les autres
poissons
osseux et comment est-ce que ça se voit
bah tout simplement
c'est fait en os contrairement à un
requin nous n'avons pas que un squelette
qui est majoritairement fait de
cartilage nous avons un squelette qui
est majoritairement phédos comme le ton
le saumon par exemple donc tout ça ce
sont des poissons osseux et nous avons
un ancêtre en commun avec eux qui datent
d'à peu près qui date d'environ le
Silurien c'est-à-dire 420 450 millions
d'années quelque chose comme ça viens
ensuite notre ancêtre en commun avec les
poissons un nageoire charnu et notamment
avec le dipneuse alors le dipneus qui
est aussi appelé poisson pulmoné et
pourquoi bien parce qu'il possède des
poumons exactement comme les tétrapotes
comme les amphibiens par exemple ou bien
comme nous les tétrapodes Amiot donc ces
poumons
une rencontre chez le dinos actuel qui
montre que nous avons un ancêtre en
commun avec lui comment est-ce que ça se
voit sur le crâne ça que nous avons un
ancêtre en commun avec le binoste et
bien il faut regarder les narines et pas
n'importe quel narine voici les narines
externes qu'on retrouve chez absolument
tous les vertébrés tous les poissons
mais voici ici les narines internes
elles sont typiques des animaux qui
respirent à l'air libre comme nous et du
dinoste donc le dinoste et nous-mêmes
partageons un ancêtre en commun et cette
ancêtre en commun avec le dinoste fait
de nous des sarcopes terriens
c'est-à-dire des poissons à nageoire
charnues on continue notre voyage dans
le temps on continue de s'approcher de
notre époque on en est encore très très
loin vous voyez on compte encore en
centaines de millions d'années
évidemment mais on arrive maintenant au
premier amphibiens et donc quels sont
les caractéristiques que nous être
humain partageons avec les tous premiers
amphibiens qui vivaient à la milieu fin
du bien c'est à dire aux alentours de
360 380 millions d'années ce que nous
partageons avec ces premiers amphibiens
alors il y a beaucoup de choses que nous
partageons avec eux déjà ces premiers
amphibiens ils devaient soutenir leur
tête en dehors de l'eau car ce sont les
premiers vertébrés à sortir de l'eau en
tout cas au moins un peu donc ses
premiers amphibiens ils devaient
maintenir leur tête en dehors de l'eau
et pour ça il leur fallait un support
avec un support entre la tête et la
colonne vertébrale et ce support ce sont
les condyles occipitaux donc les
amphibiens les reptiles les mammifères
les oiseaux ont tous au moins un
condylocipital les mammifères en ont
même deux donc ce qu'on dit occipital
c'est l'articulation avec la première
vertèbre qui vous permet justement de
tenir votre tête
élevée du sol loin du sol quand vous
êtes sur la terre ferme autre
caractéristique que l'on partage avec
les amphibiens c'est le fait que nous
n'avons pas autant de temps sur le
palais les poissons ont très souvent de
très grosses dents sur le palais les
Amphib là eux et les êtres humains et
les reptiles etc partage le fait d'avoir
une couronne dentaire vous voyez les
dents marginales on dit une couronne
dentaire qui est dominante sur les dents
du palais et vous voyez même que les
êtres humains ont complètement perdu les
dents du palais il y a que les il y a
guerre que les serpents qui vont
redévelopper des dents du palais très
très fortement prononcés mais
généralement les dents du palais ont
tendance à être soit très petite soit
complètement absente chez les amphibiens
et les animaux plus dérivés que les
amphibiens enfin il y a les zones nasaux
vous n'avez pas un millier d'os sur la
face vous n'en avez que deux qui
s'appelle les zones nasaux qui sont
situés à ce niveau là juste au dessus
des narines d'où leur nom la fusion de
toute cette mosaïque d'os en
os en naso c'est une caractéristique que
nous partageons avec les amphibiens et
ce depuis la fin du Démonia depuis plus
de 360 millions d'années on continue
d'avancer dans temps et on arrive à
l'ancêtre en commun des amiotes dont
l'être humain fait partie avec les
autres mammifères les oiseaux et les
reptiles alors qu'est-ce qu'on partage
avec les amiotes certainement pas la
faculté de pondre des œufs vous en
conviendrez mais par contre ce qui se
voit très bien sur le crâne et que nous
partageons avec tous les amis et bien
c'est tout simplement le fait que notre
crâne est lisse les amphibiens ont un
crâne qui est ornementé qui est très
très qui est très très paternée avec
beaucoup de repli de fissures etc etc ce
sont des adaptations sensorielles qu'on
retrouve chez le crocodile mais chez les
crocodiles à la elles ont réévolué ce
n'est pas un état ancestral qui a été
préservé les amphibiens ont tous cette
surface un peu paternée et c'est ce
n'est pas le cas chez l'être humain donc
ça c'est un caractère que nous
partageons avec tous les autres aliotes
nous partageons aussi avec les autres
amiottes le fait que nos yeux ne sont
pas au sommet du crâne les amphibiens
ont tous les yeux qui pointent au dessus
du crâne parce que ils se sont des
chasseurs il reste complètement immergé
avec juste les yeux qui pointent en
dehors de l'eau les êtres humains et les
autres Amiens nous avons tous des yeux
qui ont migré soit sur le côté soit en
face de du crâne enfin sur la face du
crâne pardon bref on a tous des yeux qui
ont migré pour regarder vers l'horizon
puis pour regarder vers le haut donc ça
se voit très bien vous voyez ici sur
l'être humain hop les yeux tournés vers
l'horizon et avec les amiotes nous
rentrons dans le Carbonifère donc là on
est dans les alentours de 300 avant 300
millions d'années donc entre 300 et 360
millions d'années les premiers amiotes
sont originaires du début du carbone y
faire donc de l'ordre de 340 350
millions d'années
les amiotes se sont immédiatement
divisés en deux grandes branches la
branche des soropsides ou reptiliens qui
va donner donc tous les reptiles connus
mais aussi les oiseaux et les dinosaures
et de l'autre côté la branche des
Synapsides qui va donner naissance à
beaucoup de choses mais les seuls
survivants ce sont les mammifères l'être
humain appartient à la branche des
Synapsides pour plusieurs raisons de
nombreuses raisons qui sont très très
fortement imprimées dans son crâne cette
branche dessine abside elle a la
caractéristique notamment au niveau des
dents d'avoir une canine qui sépare la
dentition en une dentition pré canine ce
qu'on appelle chez nous les incisives et
une dentition poscaline ce qu'on appelle
chez nous les molaires et les
prémolaires donc ça on retrouve ça chez
tous les synapsis par exemple 10 métro
donc qui est un des plus connus du métro
dont on l'aurait appelé avait-il si on
l'avait vu devant nous mais il partage
un ancêtre en commun avec nous avec les
autres mammifères aussi parce que il a
ça parce que il a une grosse canine qui
sépare une dentition pré canine d'une
pause canine
comme nous dit métro don possède une
fausse temporale donc qui s'appelle la
fausse synapse qui est le passage en
fait du muscle temporal qui va venir
s'insérer sur la mâchoire inférieure
donc l'os la fausse temporale se situe
ici chez l'être humain c'est
littéralement un trou dans le crâne
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça une
fausse alors j'ai dit métro don elle est
située plus par là mais c'est parce que
dimétron il a un tout petit cerveau nous
on a un gros cerveau qui a poussé la
fosse temporale sur le côté du crack
donc ça c'est par contre très typique
des mammifères en général d'avoir la
fausse temporale qui est déplacée donc
ici vous avez l'arcade du Gal et c'est
ça votre fausse temporelle c'est ça
votre fosse synapse enfin l'être humain
vous voyez il a une mandibule dans
laquelle l'os dentaire forme la majeure
partie de la mandibule en réalité chez
l'être humain dentaire forme la totalité
la mandibule mais chez Dimetrodon aussi
par exemple l'os dentaire c'est-à-dire
l'os qui porte les dents sur la
mandibule est très largement dominant
donc ça c'est aussi une caractéristique
que nous partageons avec tous les autres
Synapsides déplaçons nous maintenant
vers le Permien donc nous sommes
désormais aux alentours de 250 millions
d'années on est au permis au Trias ou à
l'époque où vivait ce qu'on appelle les
synododes donc les synodontes ce sont
c'est un grand groupe qui regroupe
beaucoup beaucoup d'espèces qui a donné
naissance aux mammifères pendant le
Mésozoïque donc on a enfin passé le
paléozoïc maintenant on franchit le
Paléozoïque et on arrive au méso et
qu'on franchit cette limite qui
s'appelle la limite permienrias
et on rencontre donc nos ancêtres les
synodontes alors que partage Homo
sapiens avec les synodontes qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui fait de nous
finalement décide beaucoup beaucoup de
choses encore une fois vous voyez que
plus on se rapproche de l'époque moderne
et plus il y a de caractéristiques
évidentes sur le crâne aussi c'est très
intéressant c'est fascinant d'abord les
condits occipitaux vous n'avez pas un
seul candidoxipital comme un oiseau ou
un crocodile vous avez deux condylocyto
vous voyez il y en a un là et un là donc
ça c'est les points d'attache je le
répète avec la colonne vertébrale avec
les vertèbres cervicales et c'est qu'on
dit l'occipitaux vous voyez qui sont
dédoublés il n'y a pas qu'un seul qu'on
dit il y en a deux et ça c'est une
caractéristique qu'on retrouve chez tous
les mammifères mais aussi chez les
sinodontes autre caractéristique qu'on
retrouve chez ici nos dons c'est le
palais secondaire alors c'est un petit
peu compliqué mais on va prendre le
temps de l'expliquer donc ici vous avez
les narines externes je vous ai expliqué
tout à l'heure que les narines internes
sont apparues chez les sarcopterygiens
mais les narines internes à la base
elles sont tu es vraiment immédiatement
derrière les dents vous voyez sont à
l'intérieur de la bouche mais juste
derrière les dents et bien chez les
ciseaux donc un palais secondaire va
apparaître et ce palais secondaire va
séparer la cavité de la bouche ici de la
cavité nasale à l'intérieur et ce palais
secondaire vous voyez c'est ce que vous
voyez ici et les coanes enfin les
narines internes du coup sont situés là
vous voyez on voit on voit plus
donc ça ce sont les narines 21 vous
voyez qu'elles ne sont pas situées
immédiatement en dessous des narines
externes elles sont séparées des narines
externes par un palais secondaire et ça
ça caractérise tous les synodontes et
tous les mammifères donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on a directement hérité de nos
ancêtres synodontes les premiers
synodontes d'ailleurs avec un palais
secondaire sont plutôt apparus aux
alentours de 250 millions d'années et
enfin ce qu'on partage avec nos ancêtres
aussi innovantes c'est la mâchoire
inférieure une fois de plus donc je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure de
Dimetrodon dont le dentaire dominait la
mâchoire inférieure chez les synodontes
la mâchoire inférieure va complètement
former enfin le dentaire va complètement
former la mâchoire inférieure donc
désormais les les os il y avait à peu
près 7 ou 8 os dans la mâchoire d'un
dîner trop d'eau le dentaire était le
plus gros mais il y avait 7 ou 8 eaux au
total dans la mâchoire de dimétron bah
là chez les mammifères et chez les
synodontes ces eaux ont tous migré vers
l'arrière de la mâchoire et le dentaire
domine largement
toute la surface de la mâchoire donc ça
c'est toujours quelque chose qu'on
retrouve très bien chez nous donc pour
toutes ces raisons là nous sommes des
descendants des synodontes qui vivaient
il y a 250 millions d'années on continue
notre voyage dans le temps nous sommes
maintenant il y a 200 millions d'années
nous en sommes au mammifères nous
arrivons à l'ancêtre en commun de tous
les mammifères alors qu'est-ce que nous
partageons avec cet ancêtre en commun de
tous les mammifères vont partageant
énormément de choses parce que les
mammifères d'il y a 200 millions
d'années finalement cesse d'être les
animaux dominants leurs ancêtres les
synodontes étaient les animaux dominants
sur la planète mais il cesse d'être les
animaux dominants ils sont remplacés par
les dinosaures et de ce fait il y a une
grande révolution sensorielle qui va
avoir lieu parce que les mammifères ils
vont devenir tout petit il y a 200
millions d'années et ils vont se mettre
à vivre la nuit et ça ça se voit très
bien sur le crâne parce que les organes
sensoriels vont ont laissé des traces
sur notre crâne le premier c'est l'OS
pétrole los petreux que vous voyez ici
chez Homo sapiens et bien ce n'est qu'un
seul os il n'y a qu'un seul os qui
contient l'oreille interne c'est à dire
la coquelet l'organe de l'audition donc
chez les mammifères du Mésozoïque il y a
200 millions d'années cet organe de
l'audition va grandir va devenir
important va commencer à s'enrouler et
sur l'os ça va se refléter sur le fait
que Ben au lieu d'avoir trois ou quatre
os qui vont te contenir l'oreille
interne il va y en avoir plus qu'un et
cet OS c'est l'OS pétrole donc tous les
eaux de l'oreille qui entourent la
coquelet vont se mettre à fusionner au
fur et à mesure que la coquelet va
gagner en importance pour fournir à ces
mammifères qui vivaient à l'époque
dominé par les dinosaures pour leur
fournir une audition pour compenser le
fait qu'il pouvait plus rien y voir
parce qu'ils étaient nocturnes et la
deuxième chose ça va être le toucher
donc les mammifères vont avoir des
moustaches et ces moustaches vont être
innervés par un air qui passe par ce
petit trou ici qui s'appelle le foramen
infra-orbitaire donc ce format
infrarbitaire va donner passage au nerf
trijumeau et le nerf trijumeau va
innerver les moustaches et que même si
on a pu une moustache on peut réellement
de moustache sensoriel même si vous avez
le droit d'avoir des moustaches personne
vous
personne vous blâmera donc même si vous
n'avez pas de moustache sensoriel comme
un chat vous avez quand même un format
infra orbitaire avec le nerf des
moustache qui passe dedans et ça c'est
quelque chose que vous avez hérité de
votre ancêtre mammifère qui vivait il y
a 200 millions d'années les mammifères
ont d'autres caractéristiques qui ne
sont pas forcément liées à leur
adaptation à la vie nocturne et c'est
notamment la distinction entre
prémolaire et molaire donc les
prémolaires qui sont plus petites que
les molaires cette distinction
prémolaire molaire elle apparaît pour la
première fois chez les mammifères c'est
d'ailleurs une des caractéristiques les
plus évidentes des mammifères il y a
entre 100 et 150 millions d'années
ensuite donc durant le Jurassique les
mammifères et au début du Crétacé les
mammifères se sont divisés en trois
branches les monotrèmes qui pendent des
œufs les marsupiaux qui ont une poche et
les places internes qui n'ont ni l'un ni
l'autre qui directement des petits qui
sont plus ou moins viables directement à
la naissance Homo sapiens est à
placentaire et ça se voit sur son crâne
oui ça se voit sur son crâne que cet
animal ne pompe pas d'oeuf et n'a pas de
poche croyez-le ou non c'est la magie de
l'anatomie qu'on paraît il y a rien de
Magic c'est que de la science sur le
crâne d'Homo sapiens on voit que c'est à
place interne et on a même pas besoin de
voir s'il avait une poche ou pas aussi
ponder des œufs ou pas parce que il
suffit de regarder ses dents il a trois
molaires les places internes sont les
mammifères qui possèdent trois molaires
les marsupiaux en ont 4 et les
monotraines n' n'en ont plus Homo
sapiens est à place interne et on peut
le dire on n'a pas besoin de le voir se
reproduire on peut le dire rien qu'en
regardant son crâne il a trois molaires
c'est comme c'est une signature c'est un
caractère qui est vraiment très
spécifique aux places internes
ce n'est pas n'importe quelle place
interne notre Homo sapiens c'est un
primate parmi tous les mammifères
placentaires il y a les primates dont
les premiers fossiles remontent à la
toute fin du crétacier les premiers
primates ont fréquenté les derniers
tyrannosaures et ces primates ont laissé
leur trace sur ses ancêtres primates qui
vivaient il y a 70 à 66 millions
d'années ont laissé leur trace sur le
crâne d'Homo sapiens notamment le nombre
d'incisibles extrêmement caractéristique
des primates il y a deux paires
d'incisives de chaque côté 1 2 3 4 vous
voyez deux paires d'incisives de chaque
côté et évidemment la fameuse vision
binoculaire les yeux font face vers
l'avant et non plus sur le côté comme
chez les autres animaux ce qui donne
évidemment cette vision en 3D très très
connue chez les privates on a beaucoup
d'autres caractéristiques du crâne ne se
sont vraiment celles là qui sont les
plus les plus faciles à voir sur un
crâne humain
ce n'est pas n'importe quel primate Homo
sapiens par exemple ce n'est pas à les
mur rien c'est un sage alors lémuriens
ne sont pas des singes tous les tous les
primates ne sont pas des singes par
contre tous les singes sont des primates
et Homo sapiens fait partie des sages
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a de différents
entre un lémurien et un vrai singe les
orbites quand vous regardez le fond des
orbites vous voyez il y a un petit trou
tout au fond c'est le c'est pour le nerf
optique mais par contre le reste de
l'orbite est complètement fermé il y a
une cloison qui sépare l'orbite vous
voyez à l'arrière de la fosse temporale
cette cloison ici ce mur au fond de
l'orbite
est complètement tipi des animaux que
nous appelons les sages on appelle aussi
ça les 6000 formes donc cette cloison
est très typique des Sims et nous
indique que nous sommes face à un sage
une autre caractéristique qu'on partage
avec les singes et qui soit très bien
sur notre crâne c'est la fusion des eaux
frontaux regardez ici vous avez les deux
eaux pariétaux qui sont symétriques avec
une belle suture au milieu par contre
ici vous avez aussi une paire d'os
normalement qui s'appelle les eaux
fronton frontaux donc une paire d'os
frontaux qui sont normalement reliés par
une suture au milieu comme en tout cas
c'est ce que vous verriez si vous
regardiez le crâne dans les Muriel mais
chez les singes par contre vous n'avez
pas cette suture parce que les deux eaux
sont fusionnés et ça se voit aussi sur
la mandibule vous voyez les deux ramies
de la mandibule sont complètement
fusionnés on voit même pas de suture au
milieu donc ça c'est extrêmement typique
des singes c'est une caractéristique qui
est apparue chez un ancêtre à tous les
sages qui a vécu il y a environ 30
millions d'années durant l'oligo 7 ce
n'est pas à n'importe quel sage Homo
sapiens c'est un grand singe alors là on
parle d'un ancêtre qui est apparu alors
en fonction de la définition si vous si
vous avez une définition qui est plus
paléontologique ou plus biologique vous
allez avoir un ancêtre qui va être
apparu entre 20 et
12 15 12 15 millions d'années mais vous
voyez que là on est on est complètement
descendu en ordre de grandeur maintenant
on est complètement au cynosoïque les
dinosaures ont disparu on est vraiment
dans un monde qui est désormais dominé
par les mammifères et on est sur un
autre ordre de grandeur au niveau des
dates on parlait en centaines de
millions d'années maintenant on parle en
dizaines de millions d'années donc il y
a entre 20 et 15 millions d'années
apparaît l'ancêtre des grands singes et
évidemment ça se voit très bien sur le
crâne d'Homo sapiens puisque ben on est
quand même balèze niveau singe c'est
quand même un singe qui est très très
gros Homo sapiens c'est comparable le
crâne est comparable en taille à celui
d'un chimpanzé il est à peine plus petit
que celui d'algorithme et comparé à
d'autres singes comme les babouins comme
comme les Capucins par exemple le crâne
est vraiment beaucoup plus gros donc
c'est un grand sage par définition mais
on partage on partage aussi avec les
grands singes d'autres caractéristiques
beaucoup plus spécifiques et notamment
la disparition des fenêtres sur le
palais tous les grands saints tous les
singes pardon ont des trous dans le
palais à ce niveau là et nous ce qui
nous en reste de ce trou c'est juste ce
tout petit foramen que vous voyez à
peine ici qui s'appelle le foramen
incisif et ça c'est très typique des
grands sages c'est même pas d'ailleurs
typique de tous les grands singes ça se
trouve chez l'orang-outan et le
chimpanzé mais évidemment Homo sapiens
n'est pas n'importe quel grand singe
c'est un nomini et comment ça se voit
il faut retourner et on trouve le
foramen magnum donc le trou d'entrée de
la moelle épinière direction le cerveau
il est situé non pas à l'arrière comme
chez un animal quadrupède mais en
dessous comme un animal bipède la
bipédie est le caractère signature des
homini c'est-à-dire de Homo sapiens et
de tous les animaux qui lui sont plus
plus apparentés à lui
cocheimpanzé donc ça c'est vraiment le
caractère le plus important chez les
hommes mini mais on a aussi chez les
hommes et Lini la réduction de la canine
c'est à dire que au lieu d'avoir les
canines inférieurs très développés qui
vont passer devant les canines
supérieures comme c'est le cas chez les
gorilles les homini eux ils ont des
canines réduites qui vont soit s'user
sur le dessus
soit carrément les canines du dessus
vont venir devant les canines du dessous
donc l'opposé de ce qu'on a chez les
gorilles et les chimpanzés par exemple
donc ça ce sont les deux caractères les
plus importants c'est partager ce sont
par des caractères que nous partageons
avec silenthropus autrement connu sous
le nom de toubaï qui est le plus ancien
au minimi connu et qui vivait il y a 7,2
7,2 7,3 millions d'années vous voyez
qu'on est encore descendu dans l'ordre
de grandeur ça devient très proche de
nous ça devient très très proche Homo
sapiens ce moderne l'homme moderne n'est
pas à n'importe quel homini puisqu'il
appartient au genre Homo donc le genre
qui contient tous les êtres humains et
qui exclut par exemple les
australopithèques alors qu'est-ce qui
nous différencie des australopithèques
va évidemment ça va être cet énorme voie
de crânienne le lait représentants du
genre Homo ont généralement une boîte
crânienne qui fait environ deux fois une
fois et demi deux fois la taille de
celle d'un australopithèque
la première c'est l'absence totale de
museau même même homo edelbergensis
avait un petit museau mais maintenant le
museau est complètement plat il n'y a
plus de museau absence de bourrelet
supra orbitaire donc contrairement à
l'homme de Néandertal il n'y a plus ces
gros bourrelets cette casquette osseuse
que vous aviez au-dessus des orbites et
le front est vertical au lieu d'être
fuyant chez l'homme de Néandertal donc
chez les Néandertal vous verriez le
front faire bizarre par là et toute
cette partie là serait tronquée donc ça
c'est effectivement un caractère qui est
très typique d'Homo sapiens dû au
développement d'une part du cortex
préfrontal mais aussi de sinus qui se
trouve en dessous de l'os ici la cavité
crânienne est globulaire au lieu d'être
ovale comme un ballon de rugby c'est
pareil c'est une autre caractéristique
qui nous différencie de Néandertal de
homologué
et la cavité crânienne aussi ne fait que
1400 à 1500 cm3 alors que chez
Néandertal et homologuy alors homologué
je le rappelle c'est peut-être Denisova
c'est un autre nom qu'on donnerait à
Denisova ils ont une cavité crânienne
qui peut être beaucoup plus grosse que
ça donc ils avaient un cerveau qui était
plus gros mais qui était pas organisé
par elle puisque ils avaient beaucoup
plus de matière à l'arrière du cerveau
du cerveau alors que nous on a plus de
matière à l'avant mais il y en a aussi
sur la mandibule et notamment regarder
ce petit menton ce petit menton mignon
ce petit menton qui rebique vers l'avant
alors que chez Neandertal la mandibule
part uniquement vers l'arrière donc il y
aurait pas ce petit rebond la mandibule
aurait bah elle serait fuyante en fait
exactement comme le front mais vers le
bas donc ça c'est aussi extrêmement
typique d'Homo sapiens ce qui nous amène
à l'homme moderne c'est-à-dire nous